[Music]
this is star talk
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist we're gonna do cosmic
queries today
everything black holes and space-time
and i got with me my guest co-host matt
kirsch and matt welcome back dude
thank you thank you i'm joining you from
my family's spare bedroom in london
right now oh you mean your parents
basement where you live just say that's
exactly it yeah i uh i commute to la
every day from
from the basement where all my toys and
games are i i knew you were full geek
but the full of the whole story you're
still in your parents basement that's it
you're on safe grounds here to admit
that
this is no judgment podcast
no judgments at all uh good to have you
back and you're the host of of sometimes
science
is probably science probably science
damn
probably science uh on which i have been
a guest in the past you have indeed i
have and i enjoyed my time there so matt
i while i know a little bit about black
holes and a little more about space time
i don't count myself among the world's
experts but we have a friend of star
talk who is of course that's jenna levin
janna welcome back to star talk thanks
i'm glad to be here sort of here i'm out
of here virtually yeah yeah janna you're
you're like a
neighbor up the street from the american
museum of natural history uh you're a
professor of physics and astronomy at
barnard college of columbia and it's
just great to have you just a friend of
what we do and a supporter of all of
this yeah i love being here and to lend
your expertise you're not lending it
because we're not giving it back
you're giving us your expertise
on
black holes cosmology uh the space time
continuum and all that goes on
uh so just before we start off i just
want to alert people that in your spare
time you actually
are one of the founders of a
marvelously conceived project pioneer
works over in brooklyn across the river
um you you merge art and science in
highly creative and imaginative ways i
just want to congratulate you
go in there and you've been and you've
been at it for like years now right yeah
i really appreciate that yeah we we have
a live programming where we feature
scientists in conversation you've been
over
we've had parties with you now yeah but
you haven't put me on the stage
i'm waiting for the right time oh okay
i i have also been there and and not on
the stage i mean they didn't want my
expertise but
i uh i went to uh yeah you and i don't
cut it yeah we just don't know for the
audience but not to actually do it i
mean i think i'll get there eventually
but i'm not so sure about you neil i i
i've got some deep expertise to share
i'm happy to put you both to work
be careful what you wish for so the big
the big project there has been lately
broadcast pioneer works broadcast since
the pandemic which is our virtual
manifestation it's pioneer works beyond
the walls where we cover art science
music tech kind of multimedia
extravaganza excellent so they can reach
a far greater audience than who shows up
in brooklyn so matt you collected
questions from our patreon members there
they have exclusive access to
our cosmic queries format and everyone
else gets to hear their questions and so
let's what do you have lined up for us
this is like a grab bag there's a grab
bag of black holes and stuff right yeah
there's a there's a really nice
assortment of questions i'm going to
start off with this one from from
matthew power my
kind of superhero namesake
that's uh but um you're matt kirschen
and this is matthew powers it's matt
power
this is matt from new jersey who is
current also currently reading black
hole blues which is one of janna's books
i've read that it's an excellent book
and matt is also enjoying it
but and matt says uh my question is if
there were two black holes orbiting one
another and generating powerful
gravitational waves
is there a possibility that a small
object says perhaps a ping-pong ball
could actually be carried away by the
waves thus making gravity a repulsive
force in this particular case wow this
is like a surfing ping-pong ball wow
love it
that's i
i
love it
i love the idea
so because
probably he's thinking deeply because if
you're surfing on a wave
in the ocean um the water isn't actually
moving it's just going up and down and
you're somehow exploiting this fact
isn't that right even with it yeah i i
think it's a subtle question i i've
worried about this but i haven't ever
really worked it out i'm sure somebody
might off the cup know the answer but
definitely
what you're doing in space time if
you're near those two black holes is
you're falling freely we literally call
it free fall so you're falling freely on
the natural curves in the space so if
those curves are changing
that's certainly going to change your
fall
for instance the earth is falling around
the sun
on a curve on a circle and if the sun
were to disappear tomorrow the
gravitational waves would radiate out
taking the time it takes until it
reaches us and then we'd go in a
straight line as though the sun was gone
right so in some sense we are definitely
moving with those waves uh but thinking
of it as like surfing it's cool i don't
know right right if we're not if we're
not so heavy as the earth let's say or
or something as responsive as a
ping-pong ball yeah wouldn't the
waves
wouldn't the expanding gravitational
wave from the disappeared sun or from
the collapsed black hole will that have
any effect on us at all to push us
how can a wave move out but we can't now
move with it it yeah i mean the this the
gravitational energy in the wave can be
quite powerful right we that the
collision of the two black holes was the
most powerful event human beings have
detected since the detection of the big
bang right and all of it came out in the
gravitational waves but actually um i
think their effect is really quite weak
in the sense you would
feel the squeezing and the stretching as
you kind of bobbed around on the wave
but i don't think it would have enough
power to actually carry you along but we
also do know i think the question was
also about repulsive gravitational
forces and actually we do know that
gravity can be repulsive so for instance
the dark energy in the universe creates
a repulsive effect on the expansions the
universe is expanding things are getting
farther apart because of the dark energy
and that's happening at an accelerated
rate yeah but you're calling that
gravity and when are we allowed to do
that yet
well there's this dark energy and it's
actually the opposite of gravity so are
you legitimately calling it negative
gravity
no i'm not calling it negative gravity
i'm saying that when we think about
curved space-time that coming together
is not the only possibility although
that is with newton's laws
in general relativity when i think of uh
dark energy as a particular source for
the way it deforms space-time we see a
very clear example where its effect on
space time is expansive
and uh oh wait wait i gotta answer i
gotta get another good answer i gotta
can i can i okay can i raise my hand you
pick on that
janet
yeah thank you thank you
so
just thinking about this more
holistically
the very expansion of the universe
is carrying galaxies
in the fabric of
exactly expanding space time so in a in
a way we are
moving
in a sense
not through space but with space
and space is carrying us and no it's not
a gravitational wave
but it's uh i'll take it as something
it's sort of surfing even if it's not
yeah that's excellent the dark energy is
just a particular example of that
causing the expansion in an accelerated
way but lots of things cause the
universe to expand like the fact that
it's full of light and energy in all
directions causes the universe to expand
and i think you really hit it on the
head neil
we are
moving with the expansion of the space
we are not moving
uh with respect to our local area right
so that is like the surfer riding the
wave
yeah yeah cool
and then we just get further and further
away from each other
eventually we won't even see the other
galaxies
for a question that is very theoretical
to one that i i know you've have a good
answer to because i know this is
something you've both been asked before
alexander new house wants wants to know
what is the universe expanding into
yeah jana
i know you've done this a bunch of times
no no i just make stuff up what i think
what i read but you actually work on
these problems so let's hear it out of
the horse's mouth
well uh
if let's take it as though the universe
was expanding into something
just pretend then we would be saying oh
there's some distance the universe has
traveled into this other space but what
we mean by the universe is the space
so there's really no logic to thinking
of it expanding into something else the
universe is the whole space there are um
some relational possibilities that you
can think of where the expansion of the
universe is like a map of the universe
where we're only reading the legend
between things as changing over time but
the map itself doesn't move into
anything else that's one kind of very
strange relational way of thinking about
it but um but no we do not need to nest
the universe into another universe to
have it expand okay i get that but
but
who
what okay so let's let's uh let's up
this game a notch
what conditions would what
dimensionality what location what what
state of existence must one have
to observe the entire expansion of our
universe
well you okay that's from the outside
so there is there is no way to stand
outside the universe no not really but
so
but so
you're trying to disprove the existence
of god with me right now what kind of
trouble are you getting into
i don't think i really mentioned god in
that nobody can see and know the entire
universe
at one time there's no way who are you
to say that you can't there is not some
platform some vista outside of
everything we know and see that can just
simply observe what's going on
well by observe we mean
collect particles and interact and we do
that
through pause in space time
so
if you want to literally be in a
position where you're gathering lights
so that you can see the universe and
deduce what's happening to it
you're really talking about interacting
with something and that requires that we
be in the same universe
now i mean you could fundamentally
you're no fun you know
we could say things that i think are
actually matt she could have said god is
out there and he's watching us all right
or santa claus he knows when you are bad
or good and then we sing some hymns and
then roll credits
it is interesting to push this idea and
to say look these ideas about space
being infinite or being finite or
expanding these are just ways of talking
we could also talk differently about the
entire universe only as relations only
as interactions and that's the only
thing we understand that interactions
happen over a certain
span of space and time and there's no
need to even think about geometry at all
or to think about the universe as a
space at all it's just appeals to our
intuition
you're looking at me like i've had this
woman on the show
many times okay a match she's crossed
over and i don't know that they're
bringing her back at this point okay
i mean and we know that we're often
fooled by these interactions so right
now i have the illusion that you're a
solid person that matt's a solid person
but really you're mostly empty space
these are illusions that we cling on to
to ease more easily comprehend the world
but we know that they're not matt is
mostly empty space yeah a lot of people
say that about me i'm solid here nearly
solid
[Laughter]
there's nothing going on in here
no no so you're referring to the fact
that atoms are mostly completely empty
yeah
right and then even if you look at
fundamentally what what the fundamental
particles are with atoms we only
understand them in terms of the way in
which they interact with things that
that's the meaning of an electron is the
way it interacts with things so in some
sense we're just these sort of lists of
interactions
yeah she got all philosophical on this
map
matter
quickly go to the next question before
this gets worse
because you got so philosophical i'm
going to jump on to scott allen's
question because scott from arlington
who who by the way gives the caveat that
scott is stoned right now
uh okay
i'm putting that right in there and if
scott is still stoned trying to listen
to these answers i think we're gonna put
him in some real trouble we should use
the donor version of this show
i'll host it and just get my mate i mean
that's basically is my podcast that is
probably like we're just winging it
don't look for stoners
oh my gosh we get all scott wants to
know best best suited for when you're
high oh my gosh you know janet we'll
bring you back that's going to be a show
i promise our audience that's going to
be a show okay
i just fall asleep it'll be a very
boring show
eating potato chips yeah okay
okay so so scott says is everything just
a form of energy is time just a human
invention combining the two ideas is
what we call life and everything we can
observe and understand with unlimited
senses and minds simply a flow energy
constantly changing form there is no
beginning there is no end there is no
past there is no future there is just
the present in whatever form of energy
we can sense and understand with our
mind
definitely it's don't
make of that what you will yeah okay
professional scientist wait did you just
give the answer and you said definitely
and now we move on to the next question
i think the answer is yes and
everything's fine right now and
i i just think he's definitely stoned
her question is
is
how do how
what confidence is do i want to restate
the question what confidences do we have
janet can you and i offer as scientists
that there is a physical reality and
just we're not all just perceiving
ourselves in the moment
and that
what what yeah
we have that i think you made it worse
for me
outside of our perceptions
yeah i mean um
we're all i mean which one of us is the
one perceiving
am i in your mind or
solely or
are you still in my mind which one of us
is a genius
started
viva scott started combining his his
ideas there are two questions at the
beginning that i don't uh that
are more grounded in i think physical
of theory and that is everything just a
form of energy uh
and also is time just a human invention
and i think i think those two are
questions that are potentially
yeah
more answerable
well to do with the first one yes i
think matter and everything is a form of
energy that is
that's interesting
know that janet
be careful how you use the word think
yes okay but you think it might rain
tomorrow but you know matter
energy okay
right it's true we know that matter is
definable essentially
yeah
and um and that is interesting i mean i
think that's also related to this kind
of tangent we went on which is that what
does it mean to have atoms in your body
what does it mean to be made up of atoms
is it means that you have a certain
amount of energy and that those uh
particles interact in very prescribed
ways that's what makes an electron
different from the positron is just the
prescribed interactions if not their
energies
so um
so yeah that's really all we are it's
beyond that to say what's real is is
again part of this illusion we have to
cope with our perceptions of the world
we'll take a quick break and when we
come back we'll pick up the second part
of that question whether time is just
some kind of a human construct
with the help of jenna levin giving us
her insights into the universe on star
talk cosmic queries
we're back
start talk cosmic queries uh i got matt
kirschen as my co-host
matt how do we find you on social media
uh i'm matt kirschen on twitter i think
mac underscore cushion on the instagram
i very rarely use uh twist is the main
place i am
okay
and if you don't know the spelling just
kind of get vaguely close and google
will find me
yeah okay and we'll find you on twitter
then without the underscore because
that's what you mostly post that is
janna tell me about your social media
footprint yeah i'm i i'm more on twitter
uh at jan 11.
um two ends like anna
and um i'm on the insta same handle um i
sort of treat them a little differently
on instagram i kind of post my personal
stuffs my personal business okay you
want to get all up in your situation
okay
you know uh yeah exactly i you know not
exactly what i had for lunch but yeah so
but twitter i have pretty serious
conversations with people if they want
to ask questions i'm there i love
answering questions when i'm in the mood
at least you know
very good all right so we left off uh
what's the name of that last questioner
uh matt so scott we left off his part of
the question was is time just a human
invention
yeah there's a quote i remember from
einstein or from his student uh john
archibald wheeler was it a time is
invented to make motion look simple
have you heard that
i have heard it i feel like it was
wheeler because he said lots of witty
things i also think it was wheeler who
said time is what keeps everything from
happening at once
all at once yeah okay
which is a good one
and just just i gotta throw it throw it
in here
i first noticed the woman who would
become my wife
in a class taught by john archibald
wheeler the
the cosmologist oh wow yeah no way i
didn't know that i was sitting in the
back row she was in the front row so i i
don't she probably didn't notice me but
i noticed her yeah yeah that's adorable
i can say i noticed her in the
space-time continuum on the chalkboard
okay
okay so what do you have to say about
his comment about
about time well i think
i definitely don't think it's a human
construct um
whether time
exists in this kind of block time model
of the universe where the past exists
the future exists every bit as much as
left and right exists but we're confined
on a particular path
through this
four-dimensional space where time is the
fourth dimension
um that wouldn't be just human beings
though that would be everything would be
confined to that space i presume my
cat's death comes before it's you know
after its birth rather and you know i
just presume flowers die
after they bloom and that those are um
things that are happening
to everything in the universe there are
other models that time is sort of an not
an invention of uh
the mind but it's like it emerges from
very subtle processes and that in some
sense it's not fundamental
but i think that again it's a very good
thing to talk about
so if we want to meet we don't just
specify
a point in space we have to say a moment
in time and it's very convenient that we
all
are able to find that moment in time and
collect and get together at that moment
in time so that suggests it's not just a
figment of our imagination or a human
construct so maybe i should save this
for the stoner edition but
if if you if you could find a region of
the universe
where nothing changes
then time cannot possibly have meaning
absolutely true
absolutely and in fact there's that's
kind of a
you know a death of the universe model
that the universe will
everything that can fall into black
holes will
possibly if the expansion doesn't
dominate and those black holes will
evaporate into random particles and then
the expansion will just make it so that
there's only one particle in the entire
observable horizon that you know and
that's disconnected from all the other
particles and so there will be no
meaning
to time passing
i mean even for me to experience time
passing there has to be change which is
my thoughts changed my breath
accumulated uh there's there's actual
measurable change that i experience as
the passage of time so
that is true that we do have internal
clocks um
but they are very well aligned with our
external clocks
making it seem as though there is
something external and
universal well while we're talking about
external
and internal clocks jeff johnson wants
to know why does gravity or high speed
cause an entity to move faster through
time
oh uh i see the question time dilation
is the question
yeah why does time so um
but first first he got it backwards so
gravity slows down time and that speeds
it up so take it up janet yeah so it
doesn't actually slow
my experience of time
so my experience of time if i'm standing
near a black hole is exactly like very
ordinary my nicely made watch that i had
once synced with my friend back at a
safe space station
is working perfectly well it's still
matching the number of breaths i take
time seems to be passing completely
normally your heart rate everything my
heart rate everything is absolutely
normal i don't get any benefit out of
this dilation the dilation is only
relative to somebody far away and to
somebody far away
i look like i'm moving slowly like i'm
breathing slowly like i'm aging slowly
like my watch is ticking slowly so it's
only uh relative to them that it looks
odd but in my experience it's quite
normal
i think the deeper question is why does
this happen and we can think of both
gravity and moving quickly as creating
rotations
between the space times of two observers
so if one observer
is thinks that this is left and another
observer's facing them they understand
that they're going to disagree about
which way is left they're not surprised
but they know they can just rotate their
systems and then they'll agree right so
at some sense as you go closer and
closer to the black hole it's as though
you're rotating in space time
so some of what you were calling space
is folding into some of what your friend
was calling time and that leads to
time almost as though you're rotating
left and to right
almost as though you've rotated time
away entirely relative to your other
observer
and um right so matt we have we should
just re-name this show stone
story
i don't think it's happening they're not
stoned it is
there is a beautifully related question
as well on this note from um from
frederick johansson
uh from sweden wait wait wait wait man i
just gotta like i just gotta wrap
something wrap my head around with what
janet just said so janna so what you're
saying is you use the left right as a as
an interesting analog to this what
you're saying is when you are in the
moving faster in the vicinity of a black
hole you're time coordinate
is
let's use the term rotates in such a way
that it's giving
of itself to this a space coordinate
and that's right so one is losing time
relative to the other
exactly
and uh just like you can rotate left all
the way into right
at the edge of a black hole in
particular
you've basically rotated your time away
entirely
and in fact when you cross the event
horizon
what your friend far away thought was a
region in space
a center of the black hole is for you
a direction in time so you've rotated it
completely by the time you cross event
horizon to the point where you think
that the dire singularity at the center
isn't a point in space at all it's in
your future and it is as inevitable that
you will crush into that singularity as
the passage of time is inevitable
and that was roger penrose
that was roger penrose yeah he yeah
yeah actually i wrote this little
article after he won the nobel prize
for that beautiful work in 1965
for pioneer works broadcast actually
because we do this series called picture
this where you draw we scientists write
about technical articles like technical
drawings and roger penrose has the most
wonderful drawing that he drew
in this 1965 paper where he shows
basically time starting to move in a
spatial direction he shows that rotation
and he proves that at the event horizon
what's happened is basically
um
time is starting to point inward towards
the black hole
so i love that and i love the left right
starter analogy there you know that
reminds me so matt do you ever hear this
joke it's funny it says so someone says
well two two wrongs don't make a right
right but then you can say but three
rights make a left
[Laughter]
do the geometry on that it works out
all right cool janet thanks for that
answer we will totally i'm going to i
will have to talk to my producers here
but i think we should rebrand this uh
for stoners aka first owners the stoner
edition of cosmic queries
keep them coming well so friedrich
frederick johansson
asks and this is related because you
just talked about the difference of
effects of both speed and gravity
uh frederick wants to know if i stand on
the equator my head would age less
compared to to my feet due to the speed
difference but would it wouldn't we have
the opposite effect due to gravity
uh
would my feet or head age more in the
end
so i believe he's asking that if he's
standing standing on the globe
his head is moving faster than his feet
because it's go it's further out but
also his head is further away from the
gravitational center of the earth
than his feet so
do these two things both have an effect
on the time perception of your head and
your feet and if so
do
do they cancel each other yeah who wins
i would have to i would have to actually
do the calculation because both are
pretty tiny right but i can tell you
that with this with like the gps units
we see the effect of the time dilation
when we send signals to satellites and
back again and they have two effects
um one is your deeper and the
gravitational
potential so so let's say let's say we
take the twins like one astronaut that
was in the iss and the other twin
astronaut who stayed on earth the kelly
twins um
which one actually was younger the one
who stayed on earth
uh deeper in the gravitational potential
well the one who was traveling and very
quickly in the iss and it's actually a
known answer i forget which one it was
i think
i think the speed of the um
iss out
dominates over
being on the earth in that case i'm
pretty sure okay however with gps
satellites
the the fact that it is they are much
farther away
from earth than the international space
station
that they experience much much less
strength of gravity
which speeds up their time relative to
us and so
their time that they send us is
pre-corrected right to
accommodate the fact that their clocks
tick faster so right janet you have to
do the math right because there are two
competing effects and yeah to know for
sure but i agree with you everything i
know about the
the orbiting astronauts which are in low
earth orbit rather than middle earth
orbit
matt it's not middle earth like
okay just to be clear
not a basement nail i'm not in a
basement it's not the middle earth
it's uh
mio uh
uh mio leo mio and geo right low earth
orbit middle earth orbit and
geosynchronous orbit so they
um
when you do the math there the
the
lower gravitational field wins out over
what effect their speed has on their
time keeping so yeah oh interesting yeah
yeah we're good interesting so thinking
about the gps we could also
think about how if we didn't correct for
the time dilation we would never be able
to catch our uber because it wouldn't it
wouldn't be in the right location and i
learned this from neil recently
that it's actually
the rotation of the earth that's the
issue
that uh that if the satellite in a let's
suppose we lost a second if the
correction was never made and the error
accumulated up to
let's say a second then if you consider
how quickly the earth is rotating and
that the grid would be changing you
would find that we could be off by
several blocks so
um so you'd be trying to catch your uber
you know in chinatown and it would be in
little italy
which is fine
these are adjacent uh communities in
lower manhattan little italy and yes
they're adjacent neighborhoods yes
yeah for those who are not native to the
city all right let's take a quick break
and when we come back more cosmic
queries stoner edition with
janet
we're talking about black holes uh
cosmology and the space time continuum
we'll be right back
we're back third and final segment of
cosmic query's black holes and space
time continuum edition which we are
dubbing
cosmic queries
stoner edition based on the answers
we've been getting and what kind of
state of mind we have to be in to even
follow them much less understand them so
janna again it's always good to have you
here your your your last two books so
one of them was the black hole blues
uh published by was that uh
uh alfred kanoff yeah by knot
yeah yeah black blues why i didn't know
black holes had emotional states
well the people who were searching for
black holes had emotional stuff oh god
okay
they have the black hole blues
so this is a story of black holes in our
field of astrophysics
and the relationship we have to them got
it got it and more recently you have a
book called the black hole survival
guide which is like a pocketbook fits
right in your coat pocket and yeah how
useful did you how soon do you think
such a book will be useful where
everyone has to have one
yeah they have to have a survival guide
uh
well i hope not very soon at all
any second now i have it's sort of a i
have a spoiler alert uh it doesn't end
well
there you go
the survival guide doesn't go well
it's pretty much many ways to die
yeah
so don't you have a book titled death by
black hole i've always wanted to steal
that title from you oh death by black
hole yeah yeah i do it's one so that's
that title is the title of one chapter
in a book that goes a lot of different
places that's right right it was this
collection of essays yeah that's right
that's right on all manner of things in
the universe that's right yeah so that's
the survival guide could also be called
like death by black hole
okay all right
it's how to not so it's the non-survival
guide if it's death by plaquemines
all right matt what more do you have for
us well i've got i'm gonna turn this to
some black hole survival questions
because we've got a few and uh and
they're great so from the czech republic
uh patreon patron gindrick uh procupec i
hope i've got that close to correct
asks you i read that black holes are
almost zero kelvin inside
why are they so cold and not very hot
due to a high pressure caused by
enormous gravity forces and lack of heat
escape
is there a temperature gradient between
a black hole center and its event
horizon and what's 0k anyway janna
oh it literally it just means particles
are so cold they have so little
energy that they're just not moving it's
as though you know what we experience
temperature what we're really
experiencing
uh experiencing is the collection of
atoms moving at a certain rate and a
certain speed on average and that
creates the temperature and the faster
that they're moving the hotter it feels
um and the slower they're moving the
colder they are and it is true there's
an expression pv equals nkt that you
know in highly pressured situations the
temperature can go up right that's the
that's the thing i the
the level of physics that i understand
like a bicycle pump gets hotter
and
if you if you spray one of those
compressed air canisters they get cold
because you're uh
yeah jenna i can't believe you wrote it
on the chalkboard
i i love the cans in front of her the
people who are audio only are not aware
that janna isn't as
you look like you're posing for a
professor photograph right now
matt was sharing his life experience
that in a bicycle pump
you
uh because he's living in his parents
basement he doesn't own a car he's just
a bicycle
bicycle pump the valve gets hot all i've
got is compressed air to keep me happy
right and a spray can as the spread as
the air releases the nozzle feels cool
so so the pressure
can or or cool it depending on which way
it's going so so what's happening inside
a black hole is is is the person right
about it being zero caliber um no
uh it's but they're not right for a very
interesting reason
so we know that as the core of a remnant
star what's left after it goes through
some very violent throws at the end of
its life
continues to collapse and is in fact
extremely dense
and probably
absolutely uh an unusual extraordinary
exceptional state of matter we know that
because we see neutron stars which
aren't even black holes they're a step
on the way to black holes they don't
quite make it there and we know that
they're incredibly unusual
in terms of their composition but
once it makes it to be the black hole
so it has created a curve in space-time
that is so sharp that we know not even
light can escape that's what we mean by
the event horizon
and you might think therefore the event
horizon in the black hole is full of
dense stuff but it's not actually
because the star can no more sit there
then it can expand outward at the speed
of light you can almost think of
spacetime as like a waterfall
raining into the black hole and it would
have to swim against the waterfall just
to stay at the event horizon and it
can't do this so it just continues to
get dragged in
with the waterfall of space-time and you
know this is the great mystery what
happens to the star we don't know
but it's gone the star is gone
so black holes are cold because they're
empty
so if i go up to the event horizon of a
black hole nothing's there there's no
dense object there's nothing solid the
it's empty space so i like to say you
know and i've said this i'm sure on your
show before black holes are more like a
place than they are a thing they're like
a place in the universe but there's
really not no matter left
but you can measure the gravity that it
has right so something's got to be there
yeah that's right it has gravitational
energy in the curvature of the space
time there is energy
in the curvature of the space time that
is a gravitational energy so it you know
it's often really hard to define
gravitational energies but in the case
of a black hole i can actually have a
well-defined mathematical prescription
for measuring its gravitational energy
and it happens to equal not surprisingly
the mass of whatever fell into it
so it's as though the matter
like throws its heft into the
gravitational imprint
but you don't but the stuff is gone
now there's another question you could
ask about temperature which is about the
hawking radiation so at the event
horizon we do think that through this
very subtle quantum process
black holes
do have a temperature actually and they
are radiating actually but the bigger
the black hole the colder they are and
the smaller they are the hotter they are
so they have they're very cold they live
their lives absorbing things not
emitting but at the end you know very
very far far far future of the universe
those black holes will eventually
evaporate away and the final stages will
be explosive yeah in fact if i remember
correctly the original paper
that described this phenomenon by
hawking uh explained these as
that they would be bursts of high-energy
gamma radiation because they right at
that last moment it would be at its
hottest and
very hot things emit gamma rays and so
exactly it's interesting
yeah so you know if you if you are
foolish enough to try to make a black
hole in the laboratory
it will explode on you because the
smaller they are the more unstable they
are and you can kind of figure out like
how big would it be
if it was like kind of a stick of
dynamite versus what you're describing
gamma rays or nuclear weapon grade and
um
and uh
you so you're kind of ill advised to
make a small black hole
but if you do you should start with a
bigger one just to just for safety
well then you're going to fall in so you
got it you know it's a so what a
trade-off that is oh and and earth it
could suck in the earth so yeah that
would be in your day yeah that would
ruin a lot of days people's days so we
can so janet we can't call a black hole
an area of nothing
if it contains the severe curvature of
the space-time continuum because that is
something
is that a fair statement yeah um i guess
right that's fair we can say
um what do we notice how she didn't say
it was right she just said it's fair
right okay hey man
you're you're right you're absolutely
right space time is something and
spaceman has energy and space-time moves
and it's a thing and in that sense it's
a thing but it's also by definition
space
which is a place
i'll i'll take that they very much act
like things black holes move around they
they
orbit they can fall together they can
collide you know but when we talk about
the size of a black hole we're talking
about a shadow that's all we're talking
about we're talking about a shadow
like the shadow of a tree
and there's nothing there
no matter there's no you know no matter
there
um while we're talking about mata so uh
listen to gonzalo castilla uh from
mexico us and
uh gonzalez mentions black mata i'd
imagine this is uh what we would also
call dark matter yeah unless there are
two different things no yeah
so i i'll say dark matter for this i'd
imagine that's a that's a language thing
um but if dark matter can interact
gravitationally with normal matter
uh it is attract is it it is attracted
and eaten by a black hole just like
normal matter right
what happens with the dark matter as the
black hole evaporates could there be a
black a dark matter version of hawking
radiation
or it only radiates normal matter and a
black hole has some sort of mechanism
that transforms this dark matter into
normal matter absolutely the black hole
will figure out how to radiate uh all of
the information that went into it if
this works so that includes um dark
matter information so that the fact that
it was dark would would come out in
principle everything comes out okay so
so the parking radiation that
calculation does not discriminate
between
ordinary matter or dark matter any other
kind of matter no it can be electrons
and positrons it can be light coming out
in the hawking radiation it can be dark
matter pairs pairs of dark matter
particles and that assumes so everything
you said assumes that dark matter is
actually comprised of matter and not
some other mystical substance right
right right and there are people who
think that black holes themselves might
be uh enough to explain the missing mass
and the dark matter
um so that's not a particle answer at
all
yeah yeah yeah okay matt keep him coming
see how many we can do
there's a couple of faster than light
questions so dylan asks um i've heard a
lot about wormholes on this show and
have a question how do we open up a
wormhole i know as of right now they're
impossible but hypothetically speaking
what steps are taken how much energy
would it take and could we just use a
black hole how do we cut space time uh
janet we're waiting for this and why
aren't you giving us the black the
wormhole
we're so disappointed
i know
i'm busy i'm i'm gonna do it in the
future and then come back oh let's
do it later good answer
good that's it matt that reminds me
during the science march which is sad
that in the united states we needed a
march to defend science
back several years ago one of the
placards said
what do we want
time machine when do we want it
it doesn't matter
that's perfect um i think mit once
scheduled a
a time traveler conference
uh for the previous year
[Laughter]
they were like let's meet in 2019
and have a time traveler conference
nobody showed up nope yeah
time travels didn't show up yeah i can
tell you this about the wormhole we
absolutely on paper know how to make a
wormhole so basically what you do is you
you you write down the shape of the
space time you want namely a wormhole
shape and then you force matter and
energy to create it and you ask then
well what is the distribution of matter
and energy have to be to create this
shape so you can go backwards um and and
and deduce what kind of matter and
energy would be required the problem is
it requires negative
energies and that's not something we see
in our ordinary experience everything
has positive energies negative energies
are super weird we some people think
that they're forbidden in nature the one
circumstance in which you can get
negative energies is in some strange
quantum situations i've actually
wondered about this could we create
where you have um like finite spaces
made out of
uh metals and the quantum
oscillations or the quantum vibrations
create a certain negative energy between
like these strange geometric
configurations so you need the energy
the negative energy to pry open a hole
that would otherwise on its own want to
collapse and just make a black hole i
guess yeah it just wants to keep
pinching closed
so that sounds really dangerous to enter
one of these because suppose you're in
one and then it collapses on you that's
a bad day
right there i'm just saying this yeah
okay so we're nowhere near this now even
though you can make it happen on paper
yeah i mean you know people at kip
thorum they were writing down wormhole
solutions decades ago and they just
looked around and said well we don't see
any matter like that in the universe
so we've got to go back to the drawing
board and think of a new way
okay so just because something is
mathematically possible doesn't mean the
universe is going to cooperate right
that comes down to there's other time
machines that we know we can make we can
take two cosmic strings which are
literally
strings of energy tension and energy
density and cross them in a very funny
way that creates a kind of cut in space
time that allows you to do a little time
travel jig but the problem is is they
have to be infinitely long and take an
infinite amount of energy so there's
never anything
that seems compatible with the universe
that we live in
and even kurt godel first when who was
friends with einstein used to walk to
the institute for advanced study with
him in the mornings to talk and he was
inspired by einstein's work and he wrote
down a description of a hypothetical
universe that was rotating
uh not our universe and he showed
that you could travel in time in these
this peculiar space he invented
um and einstein didn't dispute it it was
correct mathematically but we just don't
live in those kinds of
okay so just to admit it janet all we
really need
is 1.21 gigawatts
of energy okay
that's really all we need just i believe
it's pronounced gigawatts oh jake's
jen i think we got to call it quits
there uh we ran out of time oh shame
it's always so fun man okay
so matt with your permission and with
with i don't want to call it the stoner
edition unless we have total buy-in from
the three of us it's gonna can't be
called
i'm fine calling it the stoner edition
but anybody who knows me knows if i'm
stoned i'm asleep
and anyone who knows me knows i have a
green card and
[Laughter]
that's right northern europeans have
green cards too
i have a green card which means i can't
get the other kind of green card
[Laughter]
so we're good here so uh janet thanks
for coming back to star talk it's always
good to have you good luck with the and
it's not luck it's your talent that
helps make uh pioneer works what it has
been and what it will continue to grow
to become so thank you so much
and matt and i are still waiting for our
invitation to be something other than in
your audience
now i can't wait oh are you going to get
an invitation you got it all right matt
always good to have you dude
lovely to be here thank you for having
me this has been star talk cosmic
queries black hole space time continuum
which we dubbed the stoner edition
i'm neil degrasse tyson you're a
personal astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you